my name is Dan vinay I'm a professor of
computer science here at Stanford
University I fell in love with computers
at a very young age computer security
has always fascinated me the first day I
arrived at Princeton to start my PhD
people ask me what I want to work on and
I immediately said I want to work on
computer security and cryptography and
that's what I did my PhD on and after
that I moved to Stanford where I was
able to expand on that quite a bit half
of my lab works on system issues with
computer security we come up with
identifying potential witnesses in
systems and then show how to defend
against those weaknesses we design new
security mechanisms we design new ways
for people to authenticate themselves
more securely and then the other half
works on cryptography where we design
cryptosystems so encryption signing
algorithms that are easier to use in
practice and therefore are like more
likely to be deployed it's an area that
actually never gets boring in that there
is always new things happening in
computer security there are always new
attacks to study always new defense
techniques to invent and always new
computer systems that are being
introduced that raise new security
challenges